[Music]
joe is in salem oregon hi joe how are
you
i'm good hold on
yes speaker
um
i'm 58 years old and my husband is 68
he's a retired teacher so
we have a pers retirement
that's generous and so
we have that he we got it for my
lifetime because i'm younger than him he
also took social security at age 65
and we let his life insurance expire so
my concern is that
we don't have much in savings we um our
only debt is our mortgage which is about
144 000. good lord um
yeah we have um an ira which is down to
i don't know 52 ish thousand right now
and then i started a roth ira a couple
years ago and there's i'm not sure i
haven't checked it but maybe 10 to 15
000.
and
my husband
feels like
because we have the monthly income
unless purse falls apart that we don't
need to save anything and the the ira is
for
um
going on vacations or two of our kids
got married last summer we used it for
that too
and so it just keeps going down
and i
myself i um
i make frugality in art form so i it
stresses me out to not have something he
keeps asking me why
why do we need something what kind of
emergency and i said i don't know but i
just feel like
if something happened to you and i'd
have to sell the house i don't
necessarily want to so funerals illness
transmissions go out on cars i mean how
many times do we have to name a root
canal what kind of i mean i can name you
about 73 emergencies in 73 seconds
yeah so how naive for somebody 68 years
old
yeah i so i've been paying a little
extra on the mortgage when i can but we
have we have never put 15
towards our investments yeah um and how
old are you you said you're 50 something
i'm 58. are you working
i work part time so
you know i bring in maybe 9 000 a year
i've always worked part-time a little
bit just to make things an end to me
because we lived off of
his salary and raised four kids and we
were able to do it and i always tell
people that they can do it if i can live
off a teacher's salary then you know
they can do it but we didn't have a lot
of okay so what is what is your
household income today with the pension
the social security and the nine
thousand part-time work
it was 122 last year but that included
taking no that included what we took out
of the ira that's probably like 110.
okay you guys have to pay off this house
girl
so is that more urgent than oh you need
to be you need to be saving 15 000 a
year you need to do two roth iras and
you need to be paying off the house
that's not frugality that's wisdom
so at our age is it too late to be
putting into iowa because he has to
start taking let's see what options do
you have
going back and starting again oh wait a
minute that's not an option
you're breathing you need a paid for
house you're breathing you need some
money in investments
right old doesn't mean you don't do it
so do we put more into the loft into the
regular ira or the roth ira i would do
two roth
iras with you as the beneficiary on both
of them
you're almost 10 years younger
and i i would get and i would then pour
everything else onto the house
are we able to convert the
traditional you can but i wouldn't i
just leave it sitting there
and i quit taking it out
quit spending it you have a hundred and
ten thousand dollar income my god live
on that
i know
are you able to work more
he wants me to retire
so that we can i don't know what his
plan is does he have secret money that
we don't know about
no he put in his years as a teacher and
he wants to and he wants to play golf
and have fun okay play golf and have fun
within a budget
yeah because it ain't fun when he dies
and you're broke
yeah you're trying to make mortgage
payments that's why you called
yeah because your bells are ringing down
inside of your soul saying this is bad
this is bad this is bad and we are
telling you you're about you need to
listen to the bell it's right
okay so what percentage do i put towards
the roth i would do two roth iras that
you fully fund each of you
and then i would put everything else i
can squeeze out of my budget on this
house and don't you dare spend another
dime except out of your income beyond
those two things
so if he wants to travel or he wants to
do something you have to save up and do
it out of a hundred and ten thousand
dollar income
oh
okay i'm not sure i'm going to how i'm
going to tell him that
uh tell him you're 57 and he's 66 and
he's going to die and you don't want to
be left with nothing
i know
that's how i feel that's exactly right
this is an act of love on his part to
now start being a grown-up
a little late but it's time
i know i've told him this before and he
doesn't he doesn't see it well i can't i
can't make your husband grow a brain
honey i'm just telling you what you need
to do okay so you that'll be your job to
put his big boy pants on yeah i mean
show him that he loves you at some point
this guy needs to actually quit being
sad gum selfish and immature
and you know love your wife well sir
you know it's a that comes first man i
mean you know it's just then you can
play golf and then you can do the other
stuff and but you've done a horrible job
at saving money
you're 66 years old you still have a
mortgage
and so you know you've not earned the
right to be a playboy and fly around the
world you don't have any money
they got a mini retirement which means
mini golf sorry we're going to be on a
different kind of budget putt-putt
goodness gracious